[Music]
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk we're really doing it
good to have you we got a hot guest
special guest
how the hell are you i'm good all right
good to see you it's good to be called
special yeah not in the other context
exactly exactly well no we're excited i
i as i was saying i rarely look at the
seller lineup i was like oh you're in
town this is nice yeah
yeah rodriguez we didn't say your name
yet oh sorry my bad but uh yeah
yeah you are you by coastal pretty much
but you're mostly la when it comes to
stand-up i am though but i come here to
do my stand-up like yeah
yeah i feel
you know i bombed last night and it was
that um i heard at derek's shirt show
if you would have it it was so funny
because whose show derek um gaines has a
show in brooklyn uh okay and i did the
show um we're in brooklyn at the
brooklyn comedy club
oh
that's a tough room where is that it's
on uh bedford yeah on in williamsburg oh
yeah everyone bombs in williamsburg no
that's that's where you're supposed to
bomb that's where the cool kids they
don't they don't do comedy but they look
at us they're like we see what you're
trying to do yeah yeah
those are the worst people ever but i
had my i have i was at the i did the
seller and then i did the fat black and
i had two really good sets yeah i was on
the show you were on at the cello they
were hot i should have just went gone
back to the hotel
i should have ended there but then i was
like no i'm rick for destruction yeah i
went over there and i just had i had a
really bad set and you know when you
have a set a bad set in a black room
it is intensified right
then derrick went on stage and like
killed me after i just bought it
so it was funny that's the worst feeling
when you i remember i did new year's uh
in this awful old room called seabee's
comedy club oh yeah remember it was like
the alt to the cellar back in the day
right i remember i went on i was there
with my girlfriend at times like many
years ago and i bombed so hard and i was
like well no one's gonna get him it's
new year's literally like three words up
yamaneeka starts crushing and i was like
it's just me
man i saw dominique the other night at
like a tough room and she just talked
about [ __ ] going on like not even like
written stuff killed and i went up and
bombed
with like my tight material
yeah it happens to the best of us and
you know what it is no know this to
anybody uh yamaneika is one of my really
good friends and i adore her but the
comedy audiences now
are mixed in with like pop culture
people you don't know what stand-up is
sing it sister you know what i mean so
they're like they go there and they they
think you're gonna dance right
they wanna know you got a gimmick you
know what i mean are you going to have a
prop or are you going to bring
somebody on stage and roller skates like
that this is comedy now right
i mean i was just in miami improv that
they're like too hot it's all tits it's
all cleavage
it's all sexy and i'm the opposite of
sexy i'm like anxiety huh you know and i
bite my uh they are hot whenever you see
a crowd that's too high you're like i'm
gonna bomb yeah yeah they happen to say
irvine all the time oh really i'm going
yeah and then they go
um
can you do the skit about the like you
can do anybody's joke like you do this
skit and i'm like no i don't do skits
[ __ ]
i know it's tough you've been on you go
hard on the road
i have been you know like i go in and
out from the road because the road is
it's different now it's really different
in terms of
like uh i was in the at the punch line
and two people two tables were asked to
leave
cause they were they were told
sacramento to be quiet
and
they didn't want to be quiet
and so it was funny because the first
table was a table it was a white guy and
his white girlfriend and they were both
um
they were like you know acting up they
weren't talking they didn't want to pay
for their drinks
so they get kicked out and then the
mexicans said hold my beard and then
they went
cause the people there was somebody in
the audience that was like white
privilege right and then the mexicans
were like nah let me show you that uh we
about this light too oh my cerveza
the friday night late show of course the
classic yeah absolutely that area too
you can kind of hear like motorcycle
gangs going around tonight you're like
it's weird to be on stage oh my god how
you know it was that night yeah and i
was like the sons of anarchy are outside
don't join them it was it was a whole
thing in the parking
lot good yeah that's not a great area
hey when you can hear the outside in the
club because it just takes you out of it
immediately yeah i'm up here because i'm
insecure you're doing that because
you're insecure it's too bad right it's
too much exactly yes like if i've been
jerking off and i hear my girlfriend in
the other room crying i'm like
take me out of it we're helping it's
always about you yes exactly that is a
great club though i mean
the other shows are great no they were i
mean all the shows were great you get
your people now the yes and the audience
was the one
that went off on them i didn't have to
say anything oh i love that that was the
beauty of it all this guy was like if
you don't want to be here shut the f up
get out he was like don't worry ida we
got him i was like oh man it was that
white on white crime was beautiful
beautiful we go hard at each other
we're scared to get called racists but
we'll go at each other i feel like the
road for a female comic is just hard
it's just harder i think it's just
yeah in addition to having to be worried
about rape and murder yeah you also got
to get worried about yeah i did uh i did
a show in corpus christi texas
and they put me in like this motel that
was next to a truck stop oh boy no sleep
but deliverance in they called it yeah
yeah
it was
so this dude that was so they had a
flyer of the show
at the desk the front desk yeah
and this guy ended up knocking on my
door he was banging my door down drunk
he was a a
baseball farm league baseball player
the girl in the front desk got scared
and told him what room i was in because
he was harassing her
and yes and he started banging my door
down asking me to bet did you have the
deadbolt up yeah i always always i'll
put a chair behind the door i mean i'm
paranoid so that's not paranoid that's
like you have to it's crazy and then so
then they call the cops they called the
cops and they got him but it was just
he was just like i just wanted to talk
to her i didn't know him
but that's how weird yeah he was super
drunk
man
tough time see if that happens to me i'm
like come on in you know some some
softball lady
well she's probably not into me but uh
yeah no it's that is [ __ ] horrible
did that happen a lot
no i wouldn't say it happens a lot but
those are things that
men probably don't have to worry about
you know i walk home late i got earbuds
in yeah oh yeah
you don't do the earbuds not in public
no okay you can't even look down on your
phone damn i have a friend who is uh
she's actually a person
a public figure she was in la walking
her dog and a guy
and she was bending over to pick up the
the dog's poop and a guy just walked up
to her and started humping her from the
back what damn she's little she's small
so
there it's just out of control like
right now sorry ellie wong i had no idea
she's little i assume yeah i don't know
i know i know it's it's yeah that's
crazy um but yeah that's why we say like
mark and i on the road every week but i
always think like i mean you're uh
you're a female comic who does the road
hard you know you go hard with it so i'm
like oh man that's i respect that always
because i know it's it's a different
thing yeah even when we went to bermuda
like i remember that they're right you
guys dated no no
all right no um we we were at a we did a
show at bermuda yeah but the relief was
that he was there so i didn't have to be
by myself right
but like when you go out of the country
i went to dubai
and um i i had them change my flight i i
was there for 24 hours i did the show
and then i went back to the airport and
i wanted to really yeah i didn't feel
safe well they got women's stuff over
there it's a different different world
with the ladies there yeah i remember
there was like weird dudes in bermuda
too that was a weird thing that wasn't a
shady gig actually i know i just
remember that now holy [ __ ] i forgot we
did that that was like yeah jesus it was
just it's just
especially when you go um overseas like
we went to south korea
uh april macy and i were on this tour
and this korean man tried to lock april
in his store so he could beat her
what and we had to physically julia
lillis and i had to physically i almost
said why is if there's any good reason
he was mad at her because they hate uh
white women because it's the epitome of
privilege to them right because
in in those places women walk behind
them instead they're still
so april wanted to try on some dresses
mind you april is shorter than i am
and any if i wanted to try on a dress he
said he was like yes and then when she
was like trying to try on a dress he was
like no you too big like and
didn't want her so she was she was she
went in the dressing room to try on a
dress and he was waiting for her he took
the hook from the thing and threw it at
the door and i was like i think it's
time to go yeah oh my gosh and then when
she came out he tried to a lot he was
trying to we had to physically grab him
geez kim jong-un
it's about time these white women uh you
know they have they get everything so
it's good they get a little hardship
that's hilarious
i'm trying to bring some levity to the
because this is all such dark [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah but you've been like i mean you've
been killing it lately you know you did
the the netflix were you touring because
of the netflix thing no my hbo max
special oh no but we were with april
from the netherlands oh we did that we
started no that this was a military
oh yeah yeah and you know and then uh we
were gonna call the cops and thank god
we didn't because we don't speak korean
so he could have said anything he could
have said she was stealing
all right yeah i would have been in that
vince vaughn movie
in jail for oh [ __ ] yeah like that was
his version of midnight express right
remember that yeah yeah yeah damn but
yeah but you know what it's still
there's still nothing like the road when
you call yourself a comedian you have to
it's it's a necessary evil mark and i
were just talking before you got here we
love the road like i really i'm not on
the road this weekend and i'm bummed i
need i want it's like the only weekend
i'm on the road coming up and uh
i mean i was just in rochester new york
with
gary veeder does a road with me a lot
and
even the worst part of it like
for whatever reason i saw jim north the
seller on wednesday the night before we
went and he goes you're flying to
rochester it's the worst flight ever
it's like a shaky plane
for whatever reason the next day it felt
like we were on a paper plane the really
shaking we're landing they had he
doesn't say anything they just take back
off what because the wind was so bad he
goes and then ten minutes later goes i'm
sorry about that guys we could go a
different angle we're literally we're
freaking out because there's a woman by
the way gary's supposed to be window and
we were gonna switch but this woman
wouldn't switch with him
but like but i'm also like gary's like
that's my seat but he didn't want to
argue with her she took his seat and
then one switch
but then now he's sitting next to this
crazy woman who once the plane does that
she goes she's just screaming and we're
just like oh [ __ ]
and then
of course then we get to rochester and
we're like you know we try to make the
road fun gary's a great hang on the road
i said find a good restaurant let's go
we start walking there we're going
through what is clearly like not a safe
area yeah there's dealers on every
corner and gary's like we can make it
and i was like dude we can't this we're
gonna get robbed and then uh as we're
walking through
literally we're waiting for an uber
because i don't want to walk it a guy
gets in our face and starts [ __ ] with
us we're new yorkers and we're still
like no
then gary's getting gary goes you know
we almost died in a plane a second ago
and i'm more scared just being alive
here in rochester oh wow but we're in
all these new cities we don't know the
areas you know
colorado springs was kind of scary that
happened to me there too what it sounds
so nice colorado springs it is it is
like it's like green land and iceland
like yeah you know what i mean that's
what i don't know
you think it's beautiful
i mean it it has beautiful scenery but
it it's a different like oh they were
they were
they were a kind group of people that
came out to the shows but
walking loonies that we played that club
loonies with two e's i remember playing
there wow sounds rough yeah it was i
remember i was there at loonies uh in
colorado springs first off i have a joke
about how it's like a joke obviously but
i said the most anti-semitic thing that
ever happened to me was you know i was
in a store and i said do you have any
seltzer and the woman goes we don't sell
seltzer here that was that's as bad as
it got but that happened in colorado
springs where they completely looked at
me like jew right but uh
i remember being in the condo i'm
literally there for five minutes of
jehovah's witness bangs at my door i'm
like this [ __ ] sucks you couldn't
walk around at night it was i was in a
sketchy part of town but that club for
whatever reason they all week the
bartender's like you can have a beer you
[ __ ]
and then i mean of course i'm getting
i'm pounding beer end of the week and he
hands me a bill look you egged me on
wow that's that's the shadiest of the
shady right there i love it's like this
baseball players banging on my door
sam's like this jehovah's witness
well they're almost as bad yeah that's
true they're more persistent maybe
yeah i mean i come from well it's not a
cult because it's bigger in numbers so
they consider it a sect
but my family was seven day adventists
whoa what does that mean that means they
they practice like jews like they um
they observe the sabbath
so on friday nights the lights go out
all electricity is off until sun the sun
down on saturday and as you worship and
you go to church and they don't eat pork
like very similar to very similar
interesting and you don't drink your
family was no i don't drink because uh
in spite of all of that they chose
alcoholism and right i don't drink i
come from drug addicts and alcoholics
alcoholics so i just don't drink i'm not
a big girl it's weird to be okay with
with drugs but you're like no pork yeah
yeah right that's a weird choice well
but most religious people well not mo i
don't give a [ __ ] many religious people
are like that they they that's why they
have they need religion because they got
they need to be controlled structure
yeah they need that structure because
i'm not religious i don't do drugs i
don't drink you know i'm not i don't
live a wild life
most of my religious friends are the
biggest hoes i know totally totally i
mean look at the pedophile priests you
know all that [ __ ]
you go hard one way you got it's gotta
you gotta come out the other end those
pedophile priests are hoes yeah they are
absolutely when we say hoes we are being
inclusive
men women and non-binary people yeah
well my priest only liked the boys but
yeah he was a very inclusive oh yeah
your priest was a people i went to a
catholic school and he got popped years
later i i i was unscathed as long as you
didn't get popped no
no he didn't he didn't go for he but he
went for some of your friends oh yeah
and i was a little hurt no but uh yeah
he was crazy yeah he got in trouble yeah
wow that reminds me of a story my
attorney is a child was a child actor
and um oh i think i know who your
attorney is was he from goonies yeah so
wow but i was telling him that i asked
him i said what about all these
allegations about like
the you know people getting molested and
stuff he said
the advantage of being the fat kid is
that nobody
nobody wants to [ __ ] they stepped right
over trunk and went to corey feldman
that's what happened
so he was like i don't know any of it
because he said nobody wanted to [ __ ] me
oh my god when i was great that
when i'm a parent i would be fat kids
all day yeah
that's your your lawyer is chung from
the goonies yeah that's great and he's a
good guy ah he's the best i love him
he's my friend too like he was here he
came for my taping um he did not come
from my taping but he came he was at my
premiere that's my friend though i've
known him since i started doing stand-up
he is my favorite person in this
industry because
he does not have a problem telling
somebody to go [ __ ] themselves and i
like people who are transparent like i
don't do the phony stuff like he's like
he'll tell me he's like
you know the you listen to everybody on
your team and then like hey you know you
should do this because nobody knows who
you are you should do this and then
it'll get to him and he'll be like i say
[ __ ] these guys
you really gonna do this for this amount
of money like
and i love him for that i do that's the
breath of fresh air because in this
business it's all how you doing sport
what's up kiddo or how about this one
they love you but they're passing
what the [ __ ]
it's all every meeting you walk into
first off we're big fans i'm like well
you passed them my last seven ideas
yeah huge
people they're like we're huge fans you
own a network they love you know what
they love to tell you they they
it's a script right
and i learned it more from when you
actually work remember when you do a
show people are like we are so happy to
have you we love you so much we're so
glad you're here and then your friends
will tell you hey they said that to me
too right right you can't love everybody
i remember lou ferrand at caroline's you
know the booker caroline's back in the
day he literally in front of us there'd
be like eight comics on new york's
funniest the lineups and he would go
you're a star you're a star you're gonna
be great he turned literally two feet
away you'd over him go you you're the
best
he would do it he goes outside there's a
pigeon you yeah
you're the real king
no he would like literally everyone yeah
i mean everyone does it none of us are
special
you're right it's a script it's all
although hbo clearly believed in you i
mean and netflix i mean they get hbo
that was big for you right the hbo was
about yeah was that the biggest one you
think for you yeah that's the biggest
special yeah cause it was an hour
because netflix was like a half hour
though
i wanted the next special i i do i want
to do a half hour really
yeah because i think that the attention
span of the average person
now it because people not the only the
connoisseurs are the ones that watch for
quality that are like oh that's some
good writing this is a good comic this
is funny the average person now they
just consume all of their entertainment
like bites it's odds and and so i think
aziz was brilliant for doing that half
hour you get in and you get out
i think you're right i think you're
right because uh sebastian as big as he
is somebody showed me his numbers and
it's like a chart that just falls off a
cliff after about 38 minutes or so wow
these are his fans well you know david
tell told me that he's like i want my
next be a half hour like so many people
are just like they want it's a great way
to get new fans too you leave them
wanting more as opposed to as opposed to
as you said even a huge comic like that
right the inevitable falloff and as
comic as road comics we get to give them
a half hour and still have some new [ __ ]
yeah you know tucked away that they
haven't seen yeah for me that's
important too and you know like i i did
a documentary um for my special because
i wanted to include this documentary i
wanted people to see
how
people like me mine our jokes because
like i met my father and i did this
whole thing with my dad in the
documentary but i roasted his ass in the
special but i wanted people to see
how the jokes come to be because
they don't realize that we're just a
bunch of insecure people like i'm like
i'm like if i was a pastor you could
hold me to this standard if i came to
the church and say everybody [ __ ]
everybody in the room yeah then you
could be like hey man i went to this
church and this puerto rican lady said
right everybody but i'm a comedian and
i'm like you guys don't understand we're
we're
don't hold me to the same stance we're
flawed and we're telling you we're
flawed right there's anytime you see a
comic who's self-righteous or
anytime you you feel that uh they're
like holier than that you're like you're
the one with the skeletons yeah you're
the problem but no i agree with you
completely
and i you know it's funny because like
some of the white girls who are like the
woke white girls
you know they write think pieces about
me like they they [ __ ] it on me and just
really
yeah
because what do they say okay well cause
they asked me i was at the seller and
the hollywood reporter asked me about
louis c.k and i said
they said do you think he's coming back
i said absolutely right i don't his fan
is not his fans are not through he's not
a machine comic he has a built-in fan
base that comes from all over the place
but i was like look if you want guys not
to pull out their dicks on girls nobody
better than louis c.k to tell them guys
because he should he should be then if i
say hey guys don't pull your dicks out
on girls they're gonna be like [ __ ] you
here's my dick right but if he says it
he's the only one that can feed his
flock you i'm not so my point was
hopefully he'll come back and address it
and say it's not cool to do this right
you know what bugs me about this so too
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
no no but what i'm saying is that so i
said that and then i became a rape
apologist
and then they wrote all these people
jezebel and i'm like all you [ __ ] are
fake yeah you are performative you act
like you don't have any black friends
you don't give a [ __ ] about women and
it's only because of you because if you
actually cared about women then you'd be
on the front lines for action right not
words on you know and they came for me
and i'm like
they were demanding that i stopped
performing at the seller because louie
was performing there i'm like how many
people you think not gonna come to the
seller because ida doesn't show up right
right y'all stupid and
now you're attacking a woman like how is
it to come full sort of the irony so
ridiculous was this interview in
promotion for your special as well
this was before the special came out um
but i i was really salty about it
because
in the name of women empowerment they
came they used their whiteness and
weaponized it against me
and that was racist right now and i
didn't i didn't say that i didn't go out
and say you racist white [ __ ]
i just said
all of y'all can eat a dick because at
the end of the day i really believe that
this is all performative yeah yeah it's
all fake and it was just um the name of
clix yeah in the name of clixon also to
demonize me that's like when people
that's why i said i don't want to talk
about joe rogan or when when people ask
me i just said why don't you ask conan
oh i want to say why don't you ask me
about me if you're interviewing me yeah
that's kind of my issue is that you you
have specials coming out you're on the
road you have stuff like i i think it
takes away from you to make everything
about a dude i mean
or about any other comic why are we
talking about another comic i i always
resent that when they're like what you i
heard bill burr have the best response
to a guy uh asking about louie when it
first broke a guy goes what do you what
do you think about louis goes what do
you think about louie and the guy was
like oh he goes yeah that's how i feel
and i was like that's the best way to
just
[ __ ] you here's here's what you sound
like right yeah let me hold a mirror up
to you exactly i know you're too scared
to talk all right well stop trying to
ruin my [ __ ] career
don't ask us go ask the people who have
equal or more power those are the people
if you want to take
ask conan right you know ask jimmy
fallon what he feels about joe rogan
saying i guarantee you you won't right
you want clicks and then i i don't want
that kind of fame that's not how i i'm
with you it's short-lived that type of
fame is short money it's
it's you're going for something very
short-lived yeah and i don't that
doesn't mean that i am in favor of
sexual assault or whatever but at the
end of the day a lot of this stuff that
comes from one person's word against the
other and you get caught up in it and
then you end up being the one that
suffers the consequences for speaking
about it and you don't you're not even
you don't even know what happened yeah
like for me i didn't even have the
information i was like well you know if
he comes back he should tell people not
to pull the dicks out that's all i can
say right yeah i agree you know what i
mean who better to tell the people you
know than their hero right why would why
would they listen to me and they were
they said that i was trying to
i was being an apologist and i was being
moderate and and i needed to take the
side of women and i'm like
it's so funny when you hear people say
that like i think your side is actually
very feminist what you're saying you're
saying this is on him to do this why is
this on me yeah exactly and the other
thing is is like
i've been sexually assaulted so when i
talk about it i'm speaking from a place
of experience right so
but i'm not gonna i i'm just sitting
here listening to these people and i was
like i hate it here this is this new
this new wave of where we are now
it's like all is lost because i agree we
are operating from
uh listening p everybody has a voice and
nobody has sense yes that [ __ ] is scary
you know like yes you know what i mean
the need for the need for content has
outweighed the
it's outweighed reason well
we're talking more than we're thinking
and that's bad for anything but like
that's what happened to journalism
there's journalists now like think about
the the range of journalists it's like
there's there's journalists who are like
who's influencing putin behind the
scenes but then there's journalists who
are like uh look how ugly this woman got
from the 1980s right how many articles
do you see like that like this woman ran
hollywood in 1980s here's what she looks
like today i'm like that you're a
journalist too yeah i know you get the
same title yeah no it's crazy and they
just started doing this when it got
popular too it wasn't like they were out
on the front lines back you know 10
years ago just this became a thing and
people jumped on board and now they act
like heroes and it's funny because you
can see the monsters grow right like you
you watch people that
you never heard of before and then they
say
[ __ ] chinese [ __ ] and then people are
like ah and they're like oh they like
fall chinese [ __ ]
eat koreans out like and then it just
grows and grows and by the time it's
over they're a [ __ ] monster that
happened to donald trump
first donald trump people when donald
trump talked about running for president
before people just laughed at him yeah
and then
we got to idiocracy right right and and
listen
the trump people i hate them all
so don't think that i'm riding for
biting i hate that i hate that we have
to say that now yeah i do feel like you
do because i'll make biden jokes and
people will get upset but like i make
trump jokes they get upset i'm like hey
guess what it's the job of the comedian
to make fun of the president
i hate that we even have to preface it
with like hey i don't like guess what
we're comedians i know but we got to put
everybody in a bin now like if biden
shits his pants i'm going to make a joke
about it and they go oh you're an
antibiotic i'm like i'm i'm a pro [ __ ]
joke is what i am stop trying to put me
and figure me out and then judge me
accordingly is it funny is it not funny
yeah i got trashed in florida i remember
one of the reviews was he made fun of
our president i was like
it's a comedy show yeah but those are
the people that were shouting to shoot
hillary clinton you know what i'm saying
so it's just it's not about you making
fun of the their pre the president
people get mad if you [ __ ] on hillary
too yeah
but you have to [ __ ] on hillary you
can't
tell me show me a politician that's
clean
and i'll show you a cartoon show because
that [ __ ] does not exist no they all get
checks they all got interest and and
it's so funny that people have been
there's a ruse like and if everybody has
a mic so you see these people
dumb as hell
she attacked our president she doesn't
even understand you know what she wants
all of the immigrants to come and take
all of our jobs
all they do is repeat all the talking
points and it's a lack of education you
know when i think it really got bad is
when remember the guy threw the shoe at
george bush and everyone and everyone
thought it was funny that's the
beginning that was the beginning of us
being like [ __ ] [ __ ] the president but
also like
i don't get why you can't make
you can't make fun i mean it's like no i
do feel a little resistance when i make
a biden joke in new york or i do make a
biden joke and you know
sure yeah they're everybody's scared and
i don't know they might even agree with
you they're just like i'm in new york i
can't be seen laughing at this it'll get
worse for the next election cycle too if
biden runs again i don't know how the
hell he will but if biden runs against
it it's just it continues to get worse
because
we spend more money on bombs in school
and so you have a whole bunch of people
who
the fdr said the greatest threat to
democracy was a threat a lack of
education and so you can see it now like
and people people don't realize how bad
it is because they think
uh you know this this is always
happening it's all it has not always no
this feels new this is very crazy he
said that before tick tock because it's
gotten worse
we're getting dumber every i really feel
getting like i'm getting dumber so you
remember facebook was a lot of words
yeah yeah right and then they went to
twitter and condensed the words now we
went to pictures yeah and then from
pictures we've gone to videos but yeah
the videos have gotten shorter shorter
uh-huh we're gonna go back to vine vine
is gonna come back yeah but you know
what seconds i watch like a lot of i
watch a lot of this [ __ ] and a lot of
games and stuff kids are playing now are
very simple it's almost like there's
kind of this movement to go back to
interacting duck duck goose type [ __ ]
and like i'll watch these kids play
these dumb games like they flip a bottle
and it lands on the table and they're
like ah and it's almost like they're
getting away they have to get away from
the screen and we watch this [ __ ] like
that's so entertaining i'm like that's
what we did in our basement we were at
seven because we had [ __ ] no wi-fi
yeah but now they're doing like eight
things at once so i think it went like
that simple game and that was all you
did and then it went to like oh this is
a really intense uh rpg i'm playing and
then it turned into like i'm gonna watch
a movie while playing the simple game
right well uh on the phone with a friend
like you're doing a ton true i watched
the jerrod carmichael special i had a uh
my phone going i had an ipad and a
computer gun i'm like i should just
watch a comedy special now i got 38
things open and i was jerking off you
know what so yeah wow i know he looked
good
yeah he's a hot gay man they're really
we might be drunk as excited to welcome
our new sponsor
diet smoke most of us have had a i don't
think this edible is working moment then
10 minutes later you're on the couch and
you can't remember the word cat i've
been there
edibles can hit you when you least
expect it and their dosage can be very
uncertain that's why when we need the
perfect medium high we hit our friends
at diet smoke for the delicious delta 8
thc gummies
each gummi is infused with 10 milligrams
of delta 8 thc derived from american
grown health hemp delta 8 is simply a
slightly less potent thc the high you
get with diet smoke is somewhere between
the chilledness of cbd and that classic
stone feeling you get with regular weed
plus diet smoke comes in two delicious
favorite flavors blue raspberry and
watermelon i've been taking this stuff
to go to bed you know me i can't get
high i go inward i hug my knees i think
of my dad i cry
this stuff is top notch it's just what i
need it's like having a light beer yeah
i heard your dad does the same thing he
gets on his knees he thinks of you he
cries it's
all this stuff right here that's how i
got in this mess mess
it's legal in most states and
non-prescription just check diet smokes
website to see if they ship to your
state also their gummies are low in
sugar fat free and delish so when cbd
isn't enough and traditional thc is too
much enjoy the smooth buzz of diet smoke
that's dietsmoke.com use promotional
code drunk for 20 off your order that's
dietsmoke.com promo code drunk 20 off as
a special offer diet smokes coupon code
can be used on every order
so give it a shot come back say like
yeah i'm doing this again 20 off again
diet smokes delta 8 thc gummies are not
for use or sale to people under the age
of 21 please use responsibly
diet smoke isn't light
it's just red
hey hey we might be drunk is brought to
you by sheath underwear i i won't even
look i bet i'm wearing them right now
oh
there they are i'm not i'm not today but
i usually am he usually is i can vouch
i've seen his [ __ ] the official two
pouch underwear of comedy fans
everywhere sheet underwear has been
cradling nuts and schlong since 2013.
who wrote this my aunt
we love them you'll love them they got
it for men women it's the best they're
soft they're sexy they're slick they're
sleek you got the balls and the nuts
separated finally they need some meat
time plus that it's invented by a army
soldier and comedy superfan robert
patton he knew there had to be a better
way to unstuck the junk and sheet was
born futuristic dick pouch aside this
underwear is comfy cool and comes in so
many different patterns you can have a
sheath pair ready for any occasion and
they didn't leave out your lady drunks
either
the comfort you guys know for your balls
sheath has applied to boobs with the
sports bras tell them how to do it fatty
while we're drinking i might need one of
them
uh go to sheathunderwood.com and order
with promo code drunk to get 20 off your
first order and sheath 100 money back
guarantee that sheath underwear dot com
promo code drunk
get sheath underwear and let them
support
your ball bag yeah what more do you need
wearing them right now we might be drunk
is brought to you by disc plate
this plate is a one of a kind metal
poster designed to capture your unique
passions they have millions of cool
designs available featuring gaming
movies comics anime with officially
licensed designed
designs from bethesda star wars netflix
and many more
it only takes 20 seconds to set up with
no power tools no damages no
frustrations and once you mount one you
can switch out a new one in a flash
wow
look at that folks holy hell
look at that metal is it upside down
it's upside down oops sorry everybody
there you go the triple lindy yes
uh and with everyone that you buy this
plate will plant a tree tell them how
samuel click the link in our description
to see some of our favorite disc plates
and get our special discount 20 23 off
up to two displays or 34 percent off
three or more disc plates which will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click the link or use code
drunk when you visit diskplate.com it's
an amazing deal and only available for a
limited time and i mean that's a classic
poster classic i love it it's light it's
fresh it feels good look i think it
comes with some minis too look at that
magnet there
super cool thank you displate get on it
get your own thing
the real you want to see some scary
stuff go to youtube to the kids section
and they have these videos where they're
like
all they do is just stack something
right and then it's
30 minutes of stacking you know balls
and you and they have millions of views
somebody sit there sits there and
watches the balls get stacked in order
weird i do that in a different website
no
but you look at it because my niece
she's uh she she watches the kids stuff
and i was like is she she just been
watching
like
there you go
it's it's mad that oh i didn't but why
not don't stack the balls kid why are
you going to watch the the ball stuff
they stood there and it's like look at
that 7.5 million views wow
hilarious that's more than all our
specials put together
i should close with this on my shows
i'm bombing here
it's unbelievable like and it's it
you know and it's like other stuff too
like um
you know like slime and then what's the
slime one what is that the slime one
oh boy
it's not real slime
no but remember when people used to get
slime but was it nickelodeon
somebody playing with slime right that's
it
3.1 3.1 million look at the one above it
74 million views you see that what is
that what is he actually playing it's
just a game
yeah
this is the video holy [ __ ] four million
views is it supposed to put you at ease
i don't know
no it's just supposed to keep you dumb
so that they can
raise taxes and
right right place teachers yeah wow
look at that is it maybe that it's just
such a lack of uh
interaction yeah i mean you don't really
have to expect anything from it 74 you
know how sad it is to watch this with
your niece yeah and then move over to
your page
i'm like how do i get these kids over
here
when i was a kid i remember my parents
being like get out of the house like
they would push me out then they would
be like you can't come back for whatever
and it was weird but you made it work
yeah i feel like that now there's just
so many options that it's why would you
go outside what's making you lonelier
like kids are going to be much lonelier
now because that forced interaction that
forced discomfort it made us better
listeners yes but then
you see now on the phone it's like we've
all done the phone stuff too much you
never feel good after it no
no i put this when you do you have the
screen time thing where you see i can't
i'm terrified to look painful it's so
out the other day i was like no wonder
you don't have anything in life
this is it right here you've dedicated
your life to the interview the worldwide
do you really feel that way you have it
really it's a lot of screen time i spent
a lot of i could have written two movies
in the last year with all the money
things all the time that i spent
on the internet it's addictive it is and
they make it addictive they know how to
program it to where you keep watching
it's no different than a video game when
you ever just play a video game too much
then when you're done you're like that
was nothing
i just did nothing yeah i rotted my
brain and look sometimes i'll like do it
when i'm drunk or something get home
like it's 2 am what else am i going to
do am i going to sleep yet but when you
actually you ever play the video video
games during the day and you're just
like why
i just feel so impressed you can't even
touch it during the day yeah you can't
but if you have gym
weights you know versus phone it's just
so much easier
[ __ ] it yeah it's just it's too it's two
right there it's it's just
boom everything in here almost
everything is a bad decision yeah think
about it isn't that crazy whatever
social media app i order whatever food
delivery service oh yeah a dating app
yeah everything is going to lead to me
just being sad everything they told us
not to do when we were kids don't get in
cars with strangers right you know what
i mean don't eat food from
everything they told us not to do
we do
look how you date on the internet yeah
it's all digital now yeah facebook is
you talking to people you don't know
like it's right um
talking to strangers oh they don't talk
to strangers do you ever respond to dms
uh no because you know what the dms are
too unpredictable i'm waiting yeah
i'll get it i'll get so i used to right
so then it'll go from hey ida i really
like you i think you're funny too oh i
don't really like women comedians but i
like you right there's a lot of that one
then there's a guy who sent seven
pictures of his dick seven different
angles damn in case you weren't sold on
the six pictures
here's an aerial shot it's like passing
the furious there's all these sequels
i had to go um i tried my best not to
because
it's just you never know what you're
gonna get yeah somebody put on facebook
do you still live on magnolia boulevard
like whoa
what yeah it was crazy it was crazy
that's creepy it's creepy it's like it's
bananas on the internet it is you ever
have that thing where you check a text
i'm just gonna look at a text and then
before you know it it's 48 minutes have
gone by cause you checked the text then
you opened another thing and it's over
it's sad like when you know that adam
sandler movie click yeah or like there
was this movie called sliver back in the
day where i love watching like old
movies from the 80s and the 90s and then
this movie that sharon stone was in and
it it's like somebody that's watching
everybody in the building and they have
all these monitors and you see every
what everything that's happening in the
building and you look at that stuff and
you'd be like wow this is crazy that's
where we are now like right if you ever
like go through the reels and then one
part it seems so desperate right like
somebody's like doing a makeup tutorial
then somebody's twerking yeah then
somebody's giving you a motivational
speech then there's a new dance and you
just scroll
and you're like god we are monkeys that
can talk
it's over the dancing to me is the worst
i mean like at least the motivational
speaker's like trying to put something
positive into the world dancing like
this is just for you yeah yeah this is
you you're hoping for people to be like
you're [ __ ] you're amazing yeah yeah
what a weird mindset to think i'll dance
and i'll people will like it
no one i i would never assume people
would want to watch me dance
i'm not a good dancer it's
oh my god they go viral cause they're
like
you know like you had a big white lady
who was could get down like and
everybody was posting her videos yeah
like they're impressed that she can
dance
and i'm like this is it
all is lost well do you think that's why
podcasting is insanely popular is this
why because
people are interacting we're having deep
conversation no one does this anymore
well i think talk radio for a long time
was only geared towards a certain group
of people
and a lot of people want to hear your
perspective they love you they want to
hear what you have to say about other
things
and now podcast gives talk radio to
everybody yeah not just that specific i
used to feel like talk radio was just
for like
older
men that were maybe over 35 years wanted
to hear about what's going on in the
world like that's where the smart people
used to listen to the reason yeah right
they would be like
i don't listen to music i only listened
to talk
my mom was like that and i was wanting
to kill myself yeah like put on music it
was npr's considered
yeah brutal then now i'm older i'm i
gotta love fresh air
i think it's like fresh air is like my
favorite yeah but at the time oh yeah
yeah no the new york times podcast is a
good one like yeah really good daily
like the
in the top 10. damn you know the top 10
podcasts in the world
four of them about crimes yep
logan is one they call her daddy is too
wow wow she's huge well i remember the
new york times had when i particularly
like called the argument and it's
different host now but it used to be
two three people with all different
opinions and they were pleasant about it
it's so rare to see people because you
turn on cable news it's like you idiot
and let me finish you know it's all that
we should just shut up for adults let me
finish
but it's uh but they were friends with
different opinions we were like you can
have that stuff yeah you can still be
friends and like you know
yeah we have to you know you think
you're funny
and you think you're funny it's true
exactly so what with this podcast oh it
caught it's called we might be drunk
yeah yeah so have you done it drunk
i mean we have a full bar here yeah yeah
we but we're doing two today so we're
like well let's pace ourselves okay uh
because we're on the road a lot so when
we're together sometimes we'll do two in
a day but uh oh yeah yeah we don't get
like hammered we you know that would be
bad
that would be bad it's happened it's
happened but it's always towards like
the last 10 minutes you can tell we're
slurring and kind of that's fine mark
says the n word and i uh you know yeah
exactly it worked for rogan
but yeah it did it didn't affect nobody
every all the stuff that happened and
they were like we're gonna instead of uh
taking his money we're just gonna give
some money to people of color and get
right
right so
it felt like all right you guys will get
your chance to get on a podcast and say
crack a cracker cracker cracker
yeah cut that up will ya
that'll be the trailer
no we don't get really drunk i mean it
would be terrible i mean it's the same
when you're on stage i mean
i have those
well we i used to more it's
it's very hard to crank out yeah after i
can do but to crank out new material and
your drink it's very hard and sometimes
the crowd's hammered and they want you
to be on their level a little bit yeah
yeah but it's like and they'll send you
drinks and you kind of want to be like
hey man i'll have like one but the show
is going to get bad yes oh yeah what i
do is i have the bartender send me shots
of water
so they don't know because they you know
like i was doing a show where the
majority of the audience was they were
all white and mexican and corpus christi
yep and they kept sending shots so i
just told the bartender the that night i
said listen this is the worst gig of all
time
yeah just tell put water in the shots
and just say it's like a white tequila
the clear right because
i couldn't possibly
but you look like a badass just popping
those waters
damn yeah you're just looking at them
like you really
are idiots
i [ __ ] hate you people
you ever hated an audience oh it's tough
yeah someone's toward the end of the
show they're shit-faced and you're just
like i gotta wrap this up like
there's something so delicate about the
balance it's like that jackie chan movie
legend the drunken master when he hits
the perfect drunk level he's great but
then that one you 20 minutes in you're
like they're drunk and they're amazing
but i know at like 47 minutes this is
gonna turn you just know you don't want
that you already know you feel it when
when it's already starting oh yeah to
make that turn and you're like yeah i'ma
get out of here yeah
i had a crowd in uh
fort lauderdale last week and every show
was great but one show is older rich
people and they hated everything but
they'd go that one was good
yeah and that [ __ ] drove me crazy i
wanted to snap it's because they're
calling you like mediocre yeah it's
worse than saying you suck because then
you're like well you're wrong but
mediocre you're like that could be true
yes
you're validating every thought i've
already had and as if you need their
validation
why don't you come i know and why didn't
you look me up before you came so that
you wouldn't but have you ever walked
said walked into a music venue and said
i don't know who's playing tonight
exactly it's so weird why do you do that
with us i know you can get andrew dice
clay or you can get nanette you know
it's a big comedy's a big umbrella i
want to see andrew dyson in that that's
the show i want to see hickory dickory i
had a tough year this year
no he uh i did a show at one of the
rochester shows it was i was doing
really well but there was one guy in the
front row and all i could think was this
guy [ __ ] hasn't smiled once
it'll drive you crazy right and the rest
of his table is laughing i'm like why is
he so unhappy i'm killing i know
it's so funny how we focus on
all the we don't focus on all the
positivity we focus on the negative like
we're just like that one that's how
insecure we are we're like why don't you
like me yeah you know my father left me
when i was sick
and that's your dad you see it i feel
like it
feels like that's your dad but
statistically if you break it down
you're like there's a 300-seater there's
one person here doesn't like me if i if
299 out of 300 people like me generally
i'm doing pretty damn good
too good you would say but you want to
crack the nut you're like why
what is wrong with you yes why aren't
you laughing but we don't we don't
remember this guy could have gotten
divorced yesterday or this guy could
have uh you know
can't get it up or whatever he's
thinking about that but we make it it
must be me yeah or he could hate you
though
that's true too i hate me
we're twins what
uh any any venues you're playing uh
coming up that you're looking for yeah
so that's the question right there i
heard the first part i'm in san antonio
at the end of the month i i like lol i
have a good time
also san antonio is an underrated city
great great mexican food i agree i have
a good time in san antonio i'm going to
kansas city um
i'm going to detroit and i'm going to
peoria
home of richard pryor yeah and sam
kennison yeah mm-hmm
[Laughter]
are you playing is the jukebox you're
playing no we're playing um
it's a two-person show me and d ray
davis oh he's big it's like uh he's
doing the civic center the civic center
he's doing he's been selling out a lot
yeah he's killing it i just saw him i
watched the kanye dock and he's in it
quite a bit oh how'd you like the dock i
loved it yeah i gotta watch it i love
anything with an origin how did you get
from here to here i love how
determined he was and it's great and
then seeing him kind of get weird and
they kept it all in it's really have you
seen it no i'm gonna watch it it's great
i was told that when i watch it i'm
gonna really learn
how bad my mother was from watching it
because oh he had the best mother ever
that's what did you are you not close
with your mom no i am close with my mom
but i but my mom is not renting a u-haul
truck no to take me across country to do
stand-ups i felt in love with his mom
there's a scene where he's you know
still a young guy and they're wrapping
his lyrics from us uh sky a school
talent show he did when he was like six
and his mom is she knows every lyric i'm
like my mom couldn't name one joke
that i've written over the years now my
mom doesn't watch it they've come to see
you though yeah but they couldn't do a
joke um does your mom yeah yeah my mom
my mom's a very good mom she definitely
knows
no i can you always you always talk
about her yeah no my mom
my mom she she talks about the old jokes
like she doesn't realize that it's a rap
like that's not my thriller
you know you hate that when people yell
out like old bits and you're like i
don't remember how to do that
totally yeah i moved on i burned that
i'm trying to write a new hour yeah
exactly they don't want to let you go
and it's it's an interesting
place to where the audience feels like
they have so much power now i know i
know well they're more sophisticated the
audiences are are more
because of podcasts they i think they
just know comedy in a way where older
crowds didn't really because back in the
day you want to hear like inside comedy
it was like you know one of the it's
like on a disc yeah you divided hmv or
something yeah that was huge you know or
for us
i hate i think la is probably one of the
worst places to do stand-up um when
you're doing like the hollywood crowds
like if you go do the outskirts where
the people are that go to work i hate
getting off stage and somebody says just
a regular person will say i loved your
set i got a tag for you [ __ ]
why do you know what a tag is don't come
to the show no
they're the worst they don't do that
[ __ ] at hamilton either like
aaron burr should have died
leave me alone
what so you're doing like the outskirt
club not like you're talking about like
laugh factory and the improv it's like
the people i mean that i think the
improv more than the la factory has an
audience that really thinks because of
the wednesday shows i don't know what it
is comedy juice those people were there
every week yeah and they love comedy in
a way
where they think they they know the
terminology and they're just it's they
don't some of them don't they're not
laughing that's funny and i'm like when
you get scared do you ever say that's
scary no you just feel scared
i hate those people right but they're
they think they know comedy they just
they really do so i like going long
beach has the long beach life factory
always has like a working class audience
they come there to laugh they don't come
there to you know write a bit for it
right right but um
you know i like those like off places
too i do too in l.a i mean the outskirts
cities people are always like why are
you in that city i'm like because they
[ __ ] laugh the people yeah and
they're like
to be
only doing like certain markets then
you're only connecting to that type of
person yeah and our job is to connect
our job is to be entertainers so why are
you limiting yourself to who you can
entertain it's it's an insane thought
process and a little elitist it's very
elitist but also it's like yeah yeah
also some of those smaller cities have
the best clubs
madison wisconsin is not a huge city
that's a great club i was in rochester
that's a great club yeah rochester new
york well i'll tell you comedy was sad
when uh people who
didn't believe in vaccinations and masks
couldn't come to the shows because
they're the ones that laughed i know
they're the best laughers
they're not in their head like was that
funny or problematic i can't tell no
they just rewrite they just [ __ ]
laugh yeah they're like [ __ ] science
those are the people that's why i said i
need balance like i can't just have a
bunch of
people who
love
that they it's just it's so it's an
elitist it's a lot of people who've gone
to college yep have opportunities have
learned a lot of things and then they
come back and judge the people who
haven't had the opportunity to have that
level of education and expect you to
catch up and that's a hard thing like
you want me to be right where you are
when you just went and spent half
quarter of a million dollars on an
education
and i was working at a financial firm as
an assistant like how do how do you
expect me
and you know i got people got mad at me
because i said i could never tell my
grandmother about pronouns right she was
illiterate she didn't know what a
pronoun was like you know what i mean
like i could never tell in spanish you
tell your grandmother
i'm i'm not ida anymore i'm nosotros
she would be like call the doctor this
[ __ ] is
i'm not going to throw my grandmother
away because she has issues like she
that's the time she grew up exactly we
do have more in common and it's like we
we talked about the phone before that
you see we gravitate toward negative
comments but then when you're in person
sometimes we do with that one guy but
when you really look at the the grand
just everything around us it's like no
we're more connected than we're not like
we do have more in common and
entertainment like laughing together is
it's the best it's really awesome i know
but that that pronoun stuff bugs me
because they're like hey that's
insensitive and i'm like well so is
calling me a racist or a bigot like
that's insensitive and you could ruin my
career also yeah so it's weird that
they're like all about sensitivity and
empathy but i'm like you're the meanest
person i know you're ruining my life
you know it's funny because um
uh i was i did bill maher's podcast oh
wow so i'm alright it was cool you know
bill is bill big billy is 66 years old
so he has a very different perspective
than a lot of us and that is an excuse
you know he's also rich and
i can't relate to him on a lot of things
but i can still have a conversation with
him because
i mean i like to think that i'm able to
have a conversation with a person that
doesn't want me dead you know what i
mean
like i don't and i think bill he's cool
with me
but we were talking about like the the
differences
of um you know
where you are in your life like how you
know i i have no idea what it's like to
be will smith chris rock you know i
don't have that kind of money yeah but
it's like we were talking about how
ageism is the one acceptable ism so true
right like you nobody defends older
people like no shut your old ass up is
what they do on instagram or or for me
like i'll block you if you call me
auntie cause i'm not [ __ ] related to
you and that's a microaggression that's
you trying to tell people i'm older than
you yeah and trying to call me old on
the slide boomers but then you look at
their pages and those are the advocates
those are the ones exactly words
exactly
but you can call me oh right right and
but i can't call you soft yeah your
thing's okay but when i do it i'm a dick
but you're not a dick you know so we do
it all the time we go hey lena dunham's
fat as [ __ ] hey that's fat shaming well
chris christie's fat as [ __ ] you got
that right
i was like well if you care so much
about fashion you gotta you gotta go all
the way with it you can't just pick and
choose
not that i'm a fan of either of them
yeah but they're equally as funny
you know what i respect the people that
um can say that like
um who was it they were shaming somebody
the other day on the internet
and i was like uh uh you gotta you gotta
you gotta stand up for that guy like you
can't you can't you can't have it both
ways if you saying that this is not okay
then it's not okay for the person you
don't like either right if you don't
have fat shame you don't want to you
know want to be homophobe you don't want
to be transphobic you can't just it
can't just be the people you like right
right and that
you see that a lot online yes
that's why it's fun to agree with
someone who you normally wouldn't agree
with when you see someone on the
internet you're like i have not a lot of
comment with this person but we're on
the same just finding one because then
you're like oh wow we are
when you focus on the things we have in
common you just feel better about life
you know what i mean yeah but but no
we're we're devoid of nuance right oh
yeah yeah or especially in the internet
yeah you can't be
so even like now your team and i said i
was going to talk about it but i'm going
to talk about this you're the team will
or team chris and i saw people use that
terminology i'm team chris
and i'm like what are y'all going to do
would you say i used it for chris no but
what i'm saying what are y'all gonna do
when they make up though like the people
who are like killing each other on the
internet right right what are you gonna
do you can still say
what he said was insensitive to her
whether he knew she had alopecia or not
we know that it was insensitive and at
the same time say it wasn't cool for him
to slap him on right i agree but you
can't do that anymore yes it's that's
what i'm saying it's gotta be like
that's two sentences that's tough yes
right two sentences versus two words two
words is bam quick right yeah but no i i
agree with that and it gets it gets to
the point where it's like
you don't want to say anything anymore
if you're intelligent it's the dummies
who's ah
you know [ __ ] babies in china like those
are the people that
you there but if you if you're smart
you're like
there's no winning in this situation
yeah i'm staying out it's fanaticism
it's me versus you it's it's pretty much
the same as me going [ __ ] the celtics
yeah which i do yeah you know but i mean
it's it's like go knicks [ __ ] this like
that's the mind it's the same mindset
but now with everything but that's
what's great about sports is we we have
those tribalism those qualities in us
but sports puts it on like a surface
level it's all fun every now and then a
guy will get beat up for being a jets
fan at the whatever game but it's like
you watch a game it's three hours you go
home you know it's not this is like this
whole [ __ ] now is like so uh it's like
tribal all in oh this is my whole
personality it's my whole life the
sports thing you're in you're out
yeah
yeah i think having a black president in
this country really messed people's
heads up really i think
yeah you you guys are the thing about
comedians is that
we're like the blue collar workers of
the entertainment business until we make
it so we have this camaraderie because
we all join each other and struggle
right
no matter where you come from comedy
will humble you yeah why because they'll
be like all right you know
you got money you got a trust fund all
right but here's the this is where you
sign up for the open mic yeah but when
you when you are not part of something
like that is very different but when i
know people who were white that were
like
they could not accept the fact that they
never they never thought it was going to
happen in their lifetime and they were
like the thought of a black man being
above them just messed their heads up
and there was just it and it was people
of color who felt that way too that were
like wait a minute what we we know
everybody kept saying why do you think
they felt that they never be because
nobody believed that that would ever
happen chris rock had a bit you ain't
never gonna see a black president yeah
not in my lifetime and that was like
what 1998 he said that yeah you know
people didn't believe it would ever
happen and then when it happens
that's when people started us assembling
their cruise right you know where
everybody was well that's what started
with trump it was the birther stuff
right that's where trump really started
his campaign that's an interesting point
yeah because they wanted they needed a
reason
to invalidate him because
he would and a lot of people felt like
that
people were like he's not supposed to be
above me right you know like how how is
that possible like that was the you know
it was just and that's when it really
started getting that's funny i hear him
speaking i'm like he's way above me
that's not my reaction at all yeah but
you know it's the it's it's and the fact
that he could play basketball too i'm
like oh this is a no like he's like
really good it's not fair but it's not
us though it's the people like the
people that you're talking about are the
people who are mad that they couldn't
finish high school and he went to
harvard yeah you know what i'm saying
and it just it just messed people's head
up and that's when it really started
donald trump just put the icing on the
cake oh yeah well i take comfort in the
fact that obama's half weight
well it definitely it was like a total
swing where like you know we talk about
how everything in this country is like
it swings one way it swings the other i
mean you can't swing any further from
obama to trump
so you know then you look at
entertainment mark and i were talking
about like sex comedies how like they
there's a where they can be like you
know filthy and then they swing to being
like you know culturally a little more
buttoned up right everything swings and
like you know and then you swing and now
we're back to it we're biden we're like
well that's not i don't know what to
make of this
this hasn't swung all the way back yet
so which worries me is like maybe it's
going to swing really hard in the next
election
country was desperate though that's
where joe biden got right yeah everybody
and it was and it wasn't because i think
the average american was exhausted
oh yeah because the it was all all we
talked about was trump and not americans
and it was the all day long and though
that's why people didn't show up and
vote for him
that would normally vote for the
republican party because they were like
this is people who have dignity
you know like average people you know
your families that are they have good
sense they were like we can't do this
again this is this is a clown fest at
this point i think january 6 was like
really the icing on the cake but uh
yeah i shouldn't have done that
but you look good in the paint thank you
but uh my elk was real when somebody
sent me i know i saw somebody scaling up
the building and i was like
they look so i knew it was real because
i get all my news from kevin sorbo
[Music]
hercules
but uh no it was crazy wasn't he there
no
but uh yeah no it's been a crazy few
years but uh i heard a comic mike roland
have a great joke the other night about
how people would trump's followers would
literally die for trump they would like
think about biden's followers if he
asked you for a ride to the airport
you'd be like oh yeah i thought that was
such a great turn that's funny it's the
truth and it's a cult yeah like you see
those people uh what's his name um
what's the guy that was on the daily
show that would go out and interview the
trump people clapper yeah the funniest
videos ever like when obamacare they
were like he was like how do you feel
about obamacare and the man i was like i
hate it i think it's un-american and it
should go and they were like what about
the affordable care act and he was like
yeah that's what we need it's the same
thing
he did a great video they didn't even
know they just hated obama right exactly
you know what i'm saying but it was the
same thing but it's just
multiply that by a great majority of the
people
and it sounds bad but it's true it's
like they have they don't have good
textbooks teachers don't get paid as
much sure they got 45 kids in a
classroom that's where we are now right
but we got all the bombs that we need
all you need is one to end the world
right yeah yeah or
what we know but that's and these are
the people now who are weighing in on
politics yeah obama made people who
white people who never cared about
voting they're like we're not letting
that happen again
and they they showed up they were like
so maybe maybe in the end
it's good for the country right because
it's like well more people are going to
vote
more people voted than ever maybe it's
all this terrible stuff is actually
long-term good for america right but
should everyone be voting
you know
more people voting sounds good but
that's also more psychos voting
so it's tough it's tough to say i think
we just need better politicians our
politicians aren't great yeah i think
this will be like our dark ages
[Laughter]
until we wrap up the podcast i think
everything's going downhill and we're
all gonna die no i think it'll get
better but i think they'll look back at
us like because i think technology we
haven't we haven't reached a balance
where with technology where we're
thinking for ourselves and we're going
to have to at some point find balance
because it's
we've gotten advanced technologically
but as human beings we've gone backwards
agreed and technology's going so fast we
can't keep up we're trying to keep up
and we're really embarrassing ourselves
oh think about the politicians we're
gonna have in 20 years there's going to
be videos you're like this douchebag is
not one of you he was doing tick-tock
food challenges on his
i know right yeah
like think about the footage there's too
much there's footage of like there's a
blackface photo of trudeau yeah like 20
years ago when there weren't that many
photos think about the the ammo there's
going to be politicians in 20 years this
lady's running i have your butt all on
only fans
10 years ago and you've got my vote yeah
it's a good butthole yeah yeah some
great buttholes out there you got to do
what you got to do folks think about
that but the tick tockers oh yeah
it's all over it's all out there yeah
because everybody's got a page or a
profile it's over
it's over and then we need to forget we
always forget or act like that everybody
we forget everybody's flawed we've all
done dumb [ __ ] said dumb [ __ ] so to hold
somebody to one dumb thing they said oh
you said [ __ ] in 1999.
we can't have you around you're like i'm
not i've said i don't know it's is that
the end of the world yeah is he going to
judge my whole character based on that
yeah they even they even called me a
[ __ ] in 1999. yeah are you going to go
get those people
yeah exactly it is it you know you know
who's evil you know who hates people you
know who's hateful
and that's why i say that there are some
people that make mistakes and
we didn't how many times have they
changed the word right it went from
[ __ ] to developmentally delayed oh
wow that's the term to open micro it's
the next one
no but uh you know it's interesting i
saw this local news story this woman her
son got murdered and then she forgave
the murderer like she was like there's
nothing more but by the way i guarantee
this woman's not on twitter that's not
that's not a person who's on twitter
this is someone who like went deep
inside themselves to really be like oh
my god like you know this is horrible i
hate like i but like letting go of that
and like and we're fighting over words i
know i know like people can
it's been said to death but people can
people can bounce back i think i i think
forgiveness is a is a good thing yeah
it's for you
it's for you because you're the one
walking around harboring and the the
thing about us when people come for us
is they don't give a [ __ ] they just
trying to get retweeted
likes they a lot they are making money
like a lot of people who are i'm i'm
here for the calls they got shirts
they're they're selling merch
it's become you know like they're they
are entertainers online a lot of them
are performative and they're making
money off of it oh yeah they
they have on their their bio uh for
booking inquiries yes emailed this
person right then you go see them and
they suck they're like oh yeah because i
only knew about them because they they
tweeted about some people and why you
want to hear that person talk for an
hour right what do you have to say
that's the world we live in now i know i
know i hate it ronnie chang had that
great joke he's like hopefully twitter
will look back at it like cigarettes you
know like you used twitter while you
were pregnant oh [ __ ] that's such a
great bit uh he sums it all up he's he's
got a new netflix special look out for
him oh does he i i mean by the time this
is out in a couple weeks so he should be
out by then yeah he's gonna love it he's
a new one yeah yeah he's funny we should
we should probably wrap up right oh geez
dude great great to have you here so
happy birthday that was great
you got uh as you said you have uh san
antonio coming up san antonio um i'll be
at the san jose improv uh the dc comedy
loft
so um i have the ontario empire improv
punchline san francisco july 27th i love
that room me too because the people who
i woke do not come to the show
um
and then but you can go to funnyita.com
and then on may 6 i have an animated
movie coming out whoa so i'm excited
about that because
i've never done anything on a larger
scale than a comedy set so that's great
well they'll take that away from you
when you're not traveling
oh no you know every week i just tell on
myself every week i tell people oh i
said this yeah 807. right i let people
know in advance now because i'm tired of
people coming for me i should also say
when i was 16 i [ __ ] a 16 year old
so hope that i just want to make that
common knowledge both 16.
girlfriend it's over for you dude i know
i'm [ __ ]
all right i'm all over the place as well
my website's a little wacky uh who knows
where the hell i'll be by april 24th
keep going oh
[ __ ] paramount i love that please oh you
went back up there we go keep going keep
going hey the addison improv denver
colorado colusa california all kinds of
good stuff that's dallas basically
bricktown and oklahoma city
and san jose
staying up live in huntsville that could
be tough minneapolis minnesota chicago
you know it mark normancomedy.com
cleveland irvine where are you gonna be
at fetty gray improv uh la i'm doing uh
what else uh there you go uh nashville
uh albany
uh toronto added a show there uh what
else we got uh providence special tape
in chicago come on out tampa cleveland
you get to just houston all that [ __ ]
west palm reschedule because of my covid
from orlando sorry about that
uh yeah buffalo san jose all over love
you guys we might be drunk pod.com for
merch all they got the koozies got the
glasses uh patreon patreon.com we might
be drunk pod we love you and thank you
all right is uh hbo and netflix hbo max
yes and then they're episode three on
day ready on netflix there it is folks
awesome you heard it here first thank
you so much for coming in no thank you
you're talking this is great sunday's
[Music]
in the same way
and naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same
[Music]
[Music]